so microsoft is expected to acquire
activision for a ton of money and if the
deal goes through microsoft will become
the adoptive parents to loads of massive
franchises but that also means microsoft
is acquiring activision's 43-year legacy
and with it some legendary and not so
legendary ips they've picked up along
the way in a lot of ways microsoft
buying activision is like moving into a
house and finding all the weird [ __ ] the
old tenets left behind in the attic and
it appears the xbox daddy x phil spencer
is ready to find what's between the sofa
cushions really phil spencer told the
washington post that he's eager to
revive some of activision's old games
and let's all hope that it's not loser
suit larry so let's pull some of those
boxes out from activision's musty old
basement and take a look at the
abandoned franchises microsoft now
potentially owns
first we're going to blow the dust off
sierra entertainment cyril were giants
in this industry formed the same year as
activision back in 1979 founders ken and
roberta williams were pioneers in the
interactive medium responsible for the
first graphic adventure game mystery
house what followed was a series of
games that influenced the entire medium
games like king's quest space quest
police quest quest for glory leisure
suit larry gabriel knight and most
importantly the gold mine that microsoft
now sits upon
fan taz magoria
[Music]
phantasmagoria was roberta williams's
magnum opus for years roberta had wanted
to make a horror game but held off until
the technology was there to tell the
story how she had always envisioned it
it wasn't until cd-roms became faster
and could handle real actors that she
decided to go all in on her first horror
escapade in horror it certainly was
phantasmagoria is about a woman who
moves into a remote mansion with her
husband but is soon tormented by
supernatural forces that rip her world
and marriage apart it's dark extremely
graphic and takes many liberties to
convey its horror a radical contrast to
roberta's previous rather light-hearted
adventures when it was released in 1995
it garnered a lot of controversy for its
depiction of adult themes and violence
nor did sierra entertainment shy away
from owning it
phantasmagoria's true legacy is in
taking a daring step in using the medium
as well as cutting-edge technology at
the time to tell a powerful and
horrifying story seldom seen in games
all that said microsoft has a potential
revival for a horror franchise here or
you know they could just put it on game
pass or something at least it's sequel
however
uh well that's a box that might want to
stay in the activision attic
tucked under the stairs is raven's
software's family photo album raven most
commonly known today as being a support
studio for call of duty came from a
lineage of classic first-person shooters
like heretic or the hyper-violent
soldiers of fortune and the badass dark
fantasy rpg hexen
while microsoft now owns the mighty
fantasy elder scrolls series hexen falls
more into the doom category of action
and the potential to revive it with that
dna could be sweet to see it's also just
kind of cool to see that raven and id
software are now roomies again but then
their singularity raven's last big
outing before shifting over to being a
call of duty support studio singularity
attempted to be a lot of things with
inspirations and mechanics ranging from
fear bioshock and half-life 2 it mixed
special abilities with first person
shooting with a sprinkle of horror its
use of combining special powers into the
shooter genre was also an idea raven
software explored in their rather
bemused take on wolfenstein in 2009
which also gave bj blaskowitz
supernatural abilities and
black hair
but unlike wolfenstein the mashing of
concepts shined in singularity it's
something of a lost gem for 2010
shooters one that xbox may want to
examine for its potential in the future
now i know radical entertainment for
jackie chan stunt master
but i'm willing to bet most of you
probably know them for prototype
prototype was an accumulation of
radical's best efforts like the
incredible hulk ultimate destruction put
into an original ip setting the player
loose in an open world sandbox using
slick traversal and over-the-top
superpowers
radical entertainment was made a support
team for destiny but now that sony is
set to acquire bungie it's unclear what
radical is working on next under the
activision roof look even if microsoft
doesn't give them the chance to make the
once canceled prototype 3 they should
try to work out a sweet deal with marvel
to get another hulk ultimate destruction
underway as for jack a chance to
unmaster leave it alone it's a gem and
it's perfect exactly how it is
i'm sure neversoft has its own room in
the activision abode one that has tony
hawk and guitar hero memorabilia
everywhere and a little statue to
commemorate gun but if phil decided to
look under the carpet i'm sure he'd find
apocalypse the action shooter starring
bruce willis
now if i'm being completely honest i
don't see a future in which this exists
but i deemed it appropriate to live here
in this video as i did not know about
its existence since beginning my
research now i feel somehow compelled to
play it only to hear bruce willis
screams suck on this
while system of the down concerts play
on giant screens amidst exploding
buildings
it's a thing
and of course there's the legacy
activision has with its very own ips
that help kick this entire industry off
like pitfall
[Music]
sure there's uncharted and tomb raider
but now microsoft has its own
adventurous ip to swing and traverse the
eclectic jungles of the world i mean
but uh then again machine games is
working on an indiana jones game which
microsoft now also owns uh
whatever anyways let's not forget about
the true crime series yes sleeping dogs
was very much the spiritual successor to
true crime which was once true crime
hong kong a cancelled sequel until the
publishing rights were picked up by
square enix still activision owned the
true crime trademark until abandoning it
in 2014.
all in all it's easy to see activision
for what it is now with call of duty and
everything blizzard but it's astonishing
how deeply rooted the company's legacy
goes owning ips responsible for shaping
the entire medium stuff like the seminal
text adventure zork
of course the massive deal for microsoft
to acquire activision blizzard isn't set
to close until 2023 and even then the
deal is expected to undergo
investigation by the us's federal trade
commission to ensure the deal will not
harm competition and consumers in the
meantime phil spencer's vocalization of
exploring previous ips sparks plenty of
speculation on what microsoft could
resurrect
like
fantasma gordon
[Music]
but it'll probably likely be leisure
suit larry
yeah
anyways thanks for watching if you
enjoyed it make sure to do the thumbs up
thing and if you want more content like
this you should also consider
subscribing if you're not already okay
till next time see you later
[Music]
you